hello welcome to this video playing tau
baron ok it's a grandmaster rod from
Israel and that reminds me that I have
to message him and something really
often happen to message me a couple of
weeks ago that he has a YouTube channel
now and i did not get those messages I
simply didn't I got them on I didn't see
the memo on facebook he sent me those
messages on facebook and I never got
them and only on my messenger on my on
my on my smartphone there was something
under I don't know I don't know what to
tell you where wow you may call it under
blocked messages or something air then I
was like oh I got a message and and it
turned out to be that he um yeah send a
really nice message that he has a
YouTube channel now and the tea likes my
channel and so on I absolutely have to
message him I'd only found that out
yesterday and yeah you use hell you have
seen that I have issues had issues even
with posting my my regular three videos
so it's a I didn't manage to UM sent him
a note that i did not get the messages
so yeah I guess you can probably check
out his channel I don't know the channel
name but probably if you search for
childbearing TARDIS the first name and
berenice the second name and probably
find it on YouTube quite quite easily
yeah while chatting away I have played a
pretty pretty bad opening here yes I
don't like it at least I don't really
know maybe i can connect play Bishop a 6
I definitely would like to be white him
doesn't look good maybe even Queen c6 as
a move
taking the rook and the pawn now it
looks a bit dicey and this f4 is not so
easily player I can take c3 and you for
and okay just just drops it back yeah I
don't know the special looks entirely
useless so I'm going to try to trade it
okay probably wants to regroup once to
regroup to see for okay what're f5 it
doesn't look like a like a good position
and Bishop on before it's also an
absolutely strange strange looking piece
it doesn't look good
I haven't see a good move here to be
honest
it's not very subtle and right fusion
not not very subtle I will play nine f5
it's just a just a pretty bad position
and g6 looks absolutely atrocious
against this in this diagonal and I
don't see a good move oh now really miss
played that opening while telling my
lost message story or blocked message
whatever it was
wow what a bad position horrible
absolutely impossible to play yeah Queen
g3 it says this is the worst part it's
so easy to play I mean he will probably
also win something that is more
difficult to play with this is like not
something that my dog could win that I
don't even have one amazing check now I
totally miss place at this plate that
opening
print on the H file is checkmate what
telling me resins now it was absolutely
terrible so 93 I have forgotten what is
plating actually maybe maybe this is
just a an incorrect move or I think it
probably is 93 it's not a common move
maybe I should take here and then switch
to this kind of plane my propeller might
be better in the actual game as I said
while i was telling this story i
stumbled into this and this is pretty
awful it's pretty awful now I took
quickly because I didn't see any
alternative except I can do this so I'm
trying before because this is actually
now coming with the thread okay and this
is this position is just absolutely this
is terrible simply absolutely terrible
an unplayable position check now it can
kill me the position is completely this
is absolutely not playable I have to
take on c4 or he officially fired after
this this is seven against good play
this is lost his the last loss position
if white plays plays well and he played
well didn't give me any any big
opportunity or any opportunity for that
matter Wow yeah there was a it wasn't
absolutely unplayable opening thanks for
watching